donc je demandais qui voudrait être
entrepreneur ok il ya pour ceux qui nous
suivent à peu près 50% grâce à un peu
moins qui lève la main et qu'il l'est
déjà
ok monsieur au fond merci là la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est pourquoi est
ce que il ya si peu de gens qui
voudraient être entrepreneur qui le sont
déjà
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne se lance pas
alors les réponses à cette question
peuvent être diverses
cependant je pense que on peut trouver
des grands traits communs dans ses
réponses
la première une assez courante que
j'entends c'est j'ai pas l'expérience
nécessaire
alors cette question de l'expérience
intuitivement on aurait tendance à se
dire elle est très juste pourtant
l'inexpérience et l'incompétence sont
les deux plus grandes forces de
l'entrepreneur le fait de ne rien
comprendre à ce qu'on fait est
paradoxalement une énorme force
pourquoi parce que c'est ce qui va vous
permettre d'imaginer des solutions
nouvelles
c'est ce qui va vous permettre de
trouver des choses qui n'existent pas
ces contraintes u10 mais si vous
regardez
parmi les les grands entrepreneurs
prenons des entrepreneurs qu'on connaît
sûrement tous on peut prendre mark
zuckerberg on prend un steve jobs
comment est-ce que ces types à 20 ans 25
ans ont fait des empires qui valent
plusieurs milliards et qui cause du tort
à des sociétés qui étaient installés là
depuis très longtemps
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont abordé un
marché un problème une solution avec un
angle différent donc l'inexpérience
c'est au contraire une force
la deuxième grande raison c'est
probablement la peur de l'échec
alors encore une fois tout à fait juste
échoué n'est jamais agréable
or aujourd'hui on voit plein de gens qui
disent j'ai échoué je m'en suis remis je
pense pas que célébrer les chèques soit
quelque chose de très positif mais
échoue et fait partie de la vie il fait
partie de la vie entreprenariale
particulièrement alors encore une fois
ce n'est pas agréable mais l'échec
aujourd'hui n'est plus tellement un
problème
pourquoi parce que en est entrepreneur
il ya de fortes chances que vous
appreniez des choses en entreprenant
vous allez développer une solution vous
allez vous confronté à un marché
peut-être que vous allez apprendre un
codé peut-être que vous allez apprendre
à vendre vous allez apprendre à faire du
marketing vous allez apprendre à faire
de l'administration vous allez apprendre
à faire des opérations vous allez
devenir bon en logistique
toutes ces choses là et je suis désolé
de le dire dans une université vous
apprendront bien plus que tout ce que
vous avez jamais appris à l'école parce
que c'est à ce moment là que vous vous
confronte regrets or elle est bien ça ce
bagage là que vous apprendrez en étant
entrepreneurs vous pouvez l'utiliser
vous pouvez vous en servir et vous
pouvez vous en servir dans d'autres vies
donc échoué une entreprise ne veut pas
forcément dire que vous allez échouer
toute votre vie ne vous condamne pas à
l'échec et par conséquent ça devrait
libérer le les potentialités
d'entreprise chez chacun il ne faut pas
avoir peur d'échouer donc voilà pour les
raisons qu'on entend souvent
l'inexpérience l'échec
ce ne sont pas vraiment des vrais
problèmes c'est plutôt des choses qu'on
se dit pour éviter de se lancer ou pour
ne pas se confronter à l'entrepreneuriat
à côté de ces fausses bonnes raisons de
ne pas se lancer il ya des fausses
bonnes raisons de se lancer
les fausses bonnes raisons de se lancer
elles sont assez simples
la première c'est se lancer parce que
c'est cool alors il ya deux trois ans on
disait pas ça c'est quelque chose de
nouveau mais aujourd'hui devenir
entrepreneur c'est de devenir c'est
plutôt cool
les entrepreneurs font la une de
challenge aujourd'hui moi mes parents à
chaque fois qu'ils voient quelque chose
qui a un minimum de lien avec mon
industrie me l'envoie pour ma boîte
parce qu'on sait jamais ça peut me
servir ce genre de petit signe ça
existait pas
aujourd'hui c'est bien que
l'entrepreneur à survaloriser encore
heureux on a de la chance mais il faut
pas confondre entreprendre parce qu'on a
envie de vivre cette vie là où
entreprendre parce qu'on résout un
problème qui compte
et entre points parce qu'on a envie de
vivre cette vie là malheureusement ça ne
fait pas faire des entreprises ça fait
faire des concours
ça se fait faire des félicitations par
votre papa à votre moment mais ça ne
vous fait pas faire une entreprise
la deuxième fausse bonne raison de se
lancer c'est pour l'argent
alors encore une fois on peut penser
intuitivement qu'entreprendre c'est pour
devenir riche car entreprendre c'est
pour créer une société a priori si on
veut créer une société cette société à
la but lucratif je parle pas de lancer
une association je parle pas de lancer
une ong
je pars de lancer une entreprise c'est
pour gagner de l'argent
pourtant l'espérance moyenne d'un
entrepreneur allait probablement
inférieures à zéro il ya plus de gens
qui perdent que de gens qui gagnent et
si on prend toute l'énergie en temps et
en argent qui investit dans cet
écosystème
il est probable il est très probable
qu'il n'en rendent pas autant et encore
une fois c'est paradoxal parce que vous
voyez ces grandes histoires de succès
mais le succès c'est toujours une
évidence rétrospective
c'est facile de dire j'aurais pu lancer
facebook
c'est facile de dire j'aurais pu acheter
100 bitcoin à 10 centimes et aujourd'hui
ça vaut dix mille dollars
11000 12000 je ne sais pas s'ils
augmentent chaque minute c'est facile
tout ça mais c'est toujours des
évidences rétrospective ce ne n'est pas
malheureusement quelque chose avec
lequel vous pouvez partir et il faut
s'en méfier car encore une fois
l'espérance de gain et probablement
négative c'est un monde où très peu
gagne beaucoup et où beaucoup perdent un
peu pas grave de perdre un peu mais vous
si vous voulez devenir riche
devenez probablement consultant trader à
la société générale ou ce que vous
voulez vous aurez certainement beaucoup
plus de chances de gains que
l'entrepreneur moyens qui sens alors au
milieu de tout ça il ya les bonnes
raisons de se lancer et pourquoi est ce
qu'il faut le faire
ces bonnes raisons on peut trouver à peu
près deux grands types d'entrepreneurs
alors encore une fois c'est pas une
liste exhaustive on pourrait y passer la
soirée
mais les deux grands types
d'entrepreneurs qu'on peut trouver
c'est ce qui se lance parce qu'ils ont
un problème qui leur tiennent à coeur et
ceux qui se lancent pas ce qu'ils aiment
le jeu la première catégorie elle est
assez simple j'aime bien faire ce petit
test est ce qu'il y en a ici qui
connaissent la société agri cool
quelques-uns agri cool c'est une société
française qui est un très bon exemple de
ça
ses deux fils d'agriculteurs qui sont
venus à paris pour leurs études
d'habitude ils avaient des fraises dans
leur jardin puis là ils ont acheté des
fraises au supermarché ils ont trouvé ça
infecte et ils se sont dit comment est
ce que des fraises peuvent être aussi
mauvaise
alors que nous on est a toujours vu on
est toujours cueillir rouge d'anglais
est en fait ils ont réalisé que la
chaîne de production de ces fraises
était passablement mauvaises sont
importés du brésil elles sont cueillies
blanches elles mûrissent sous des bâches
sur des bateaux elle arrive à paris
chaîne de valeur un peu bizarre ils sont
dit pourquoi est ce qu'on ne fait pas
pour est ce qu on les cultive pas de
manière organique de ma de manière bio
localement et on les cueille et ils ont
créé une société où qui permet en fait
de cultiver ses fraises dans un
conteneur sur des plans mais sans ogm
sans pesticides uniquement avec de la
lumière de la terre et de l'eau
la raison pour laquelle ils se sont
lancés plutôt que de devenir ingénieur
agronome ce qu'ils auraient pu faire
dans n'importe quelle boîte la raison
pour laquelle ils ont voulu créer agri
cool c'est parce que il avait une cause
qui leur tenait à coeur le bien manger
dans les villes et vous pouvez en
trouver plein des entrepreneurs comme ça
à côté de cette catégorie qu'on connaît
bien et que tous les entrepreneurs et
ses dettes car elle est beaucoup plus
facile à a marqué t elle est beaucoup
plus facile à vendre et à la catégorie
des entrepreneurs qui font ça parce
qu'ils aiment jouer alors on est dans
universités de technologie donc je pense
que ça parlera à beaucoup d'entre vous
de même qu'un à certains qu'ils aiment
résoudre des problèmes de maths il y en
a qui aiment le jeu entreprenariale l'un
qui aime s'attaquer à un secteur et se
dire comment est ce que je vais pouvoir
changer ce secteur comment est ce que je
vais pouvoir avoir un impact sur ce
secteur j'ai pas donné de nom parce que
c'est les 1ers vrai probablement mais il
y en a beaucoup
dans le monde entrepreneurial et c'est
une très grande qualité car encore une
fois c'est ce qui vous permet d'aborder
un secteur avec un oeil neuf et des
secteurs aussi qu'ils sont moins sexy
que d'autres eh bien ces deux raisons là
c'est des raisons parfaitement valable
de se lancer parce que ça vous fait vous
lancer avec une vision avec l' envie de
s'attaquer à un problème ça c'est pour
le pourquoi entreprendre
maintenant il ya le comment l'entreprise
ou bien le commencer de trouver le
problème auquel vous allez vous attaquer
c'est la première étape de
l'entrepreneuriat un billet qu'on a
beaucoup c'est de réfléchir beaucoup
plus aux solutions aux problèmes or ce
qui compte c'est le problème facebook
ça répond au problème de connecter les
gens tesla
ça répond au problème de déplacer les
gens vous pouvez prendre toutes les
boîtes comme ça elles répondent tout un
problème avec des solutions plus ou
moins différentes
pourquoi est ce que le problème compte
plus que la solution c'est pour une
raison simple c'est que la solution à la
de valeur que dans la tête des
entrepreneurs une solution elle n'a de
valeur que si elle est adoptée par le
marché est donc temps que vous ne la
confronter pas au marché elle n'a de
valeur que pour vous alors qu'un
problème il a une valeur en soi
le problème de transporter les gens
c'est un vrai problème que ce soit en
train que son voiture que ce soit en
skate que ce soit en trottinette ce que
vous voulez c'est un problème
idem pour le brame de se parler de se
connecter
dème pour le problème de s'informer bref
vous pouvez vendre à peu près tous les
grands problèmes humains il n'y en a pas
tant que ça et c'est à partir de ce
moment là vous pouvez commencer à
trouver une solution est donc dans votre
esprit il faut d'abord trouver le
problème est ensuite trouvé la solution
pour faire ce qu'on appelle désolé pour
cet anglicisme un product marketing
c'est à dire une adéquation entre un
produit et un marché et c'est la clé de
voûte de l'entrepreneuriat c'est à ce
moment là que l'entreprise commence
et c'est aussi la principale raison
d'échecs des entrepreneurs 99 % des
entreprises des start-up rate parce
qu'elles font quelque chose dont
personne n'a quelque chose à faire c'est
cruel mais c'est comme ça parce que les
entrepreneurs sont partis avec la
solution en tête plutôt qu'avec le
problème trouver ce product marketing
trouvé cette adéquation entre la
solution qu'on propose est un problème
qu'on attaque
c'est un peu comme chercher du pétrole
il faut creuser à plein d'endroits
jusqu'à temps de trouver la bonne nappe
celle que vous aller exploiter
donc malheureusement ça ne peut pas
prédire si quelqu'un savait prédire ce
genre de découverte
il passerait toute sa vie et créer des
boîtes et serait à l'heure actuelle
probablement l'homme le plus riche de la
planète mais c'est pas le cas c'est le
cas parce que on est tous humains et en
tant que consommateur on a des avis un
peu différent des envies un peu
différentes et donc j'aime des choses
que vous n'allez pas forcément aimer et
vice versa et donc le rôle de
l'entrepreneur c'est de trouver
suffisamment de gens qui sont séduits
par sa solution pour pouvoir se dire ok
j'ai me lancer là dessus le deuxième
concept un petit peu compliqué à
comprendre quand on se lance
c'est le succès une fois qu'on a trouvé
son problème
une fois qu'on expérimente la solution
comment on sait que la solution va
fonctionner ou pas et encore une fois
j'aimerais attirer votre attention sur
le fait que les évidences rétrospective
c'est toujours très facile mais quand
vous êtes entrepreneur malheureusement
il ya personne pour vous dire si vous
êtes sur la voie du succès ou pas à 30
ans preneur c'est un peu comme traverser
la manche à la nage
quand vous partez sur la plage au début
tout le monde est très très très très à
fond derrière vous c'est génial
vas-y on t'encourage quand vous arrivez
tout le monde vous félicite vous avez
traversé la manche à la nage c'est pas
rien ça fait quoi 50 km mais alors quand
vous êtes entre les deux
vous êtes tout seul dans l'eau froide
voyez les types sur leurs bateaux qui
passent qui font qu est-ce qui fait là
lui et c'est toujours le problème de
l'entrepreneur c'est que il faut aimer
la traversée plus que le point de départ
ou d'arrivée et le problème c'est qu'on
sait jamais si on est dans la bonne
direction car le succès c'est toujours
une évidence au moment où ils arrivent
ça ne l'est jamais au moment où ils
secret est donc ce qui est compliqué
dans le fait de trouver la bonne
solution à son problème c'est qu'on a
toujours du mal à savoir si on est sur
la bonne route
alors pour ça vous pouvez être très dur
avec vous même et vous dire que le
succès c'est ça doit être une évidence
et donc si vous sentez pas que vous en
êtes à un moment où c'est votre
entreprise qui vous pousse et pas vous
qui poussez votre entreprise c'est
probablement que vous avez pas encore
trouvé ce moment où vois tu solution
rencontre marché ce que les américains
appellent success is obviously le succès
est évident pourquoi parce qu'en fait
quand vous prenez à peu près toutes les
histoires de sociétés qui ont réussi
elles ont toujours connu une phase début
qui n'était pas très sexy où il se
passait pas grand chose et puis tout à
coup la croissance a explosé et quand la
croissance explose c'est ce moment où la
start up se met à croître
tellement rapidement que vous n'arrivez
quasiment plus à répondre à la demande
ça devient trop compliqué on vous
sollicite et puis vous vous avez plus
les produits il faut il faut vendre
toujours toujours et c'est là que ça
devient compliqué mais c'est aussi là où
vous voyez que vous avez un véritable
succès et donc c'est la première clé de
voûte de l'entrepreneur évidemment
savait pas dire que le succès est assuré
car je vous ai dit qu'il y avait 99 %
des start up qui se planquent tu es à
cet espace vous passez à ceux à ce
passage là entre solutions et et marché
mais une fois sûr que vous avez passé
cette étape là sur les 1 % qui restent
il ya à nouveau 99% qui se plante pour
d'autres raisons
c'est pas pour vous décourager que je
vous dis ça parce que c'est vrai il faut
en être conscient au moment où on se
lance
entreprendre est quelque chose de
fondamentalement dur et encore une fois
il faut aimer la traversée plus tôt que
le départ et l'arrivée et aimer la
traversée c'est à dire aimé comprendre
ça alors la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
ya plein de solutions pour que ce soit
plus simple et notamment y en a une qui
est très pratique qui vous permet de
tester la demande pour votre solution
avant même de construire la solution car
quel est le problème quand ça échoue le
problème c'est que vous avez investi du
temps vous avez investi de l'argent dans
quelque chose qui ne marche pas et c'est
ce que vous voulez absolument éviter si
vous vous lancez comment faire eh ben il
ya une solution très simple c'est de
faire semblant que le produit existe le
vendre et ensuite le fabriquer qui
connaît kickstarter ici et ben kickstart
7 plus en plus de mains chaque année 20
kickstarter c'est l'exemple type de ça
sur kickstarter vous avez des gens qui
proposent un produit qui n'existe pas il
faut une jolie vidéo
ils demandent de l'argent et ils disent
que si les gens achètent et ben c'est
probablement que ça vaudra le coup de le
mettre en production
l'intérêt du monde dans lequel on vit
c'est que vous pouvez faire ça pour à
peu près n'importe quoi vous pouvez
faire ça pour un logiciel pouvait faire
ça pour un produit pouvait faire ça pour
un service tout le monde connaît dropbox
ici peu près
dropbox est un cas intéressant quand
drew houston est sorti du ml ti et qu'il
a voulu créer dropbox
il a commencé à le développer mais pour
que tout soit bien sécurisé cueillez pas
de perte de fichiers qui ait pas de
perte de données
il fallait des ingénieurs il lui fallait
des fonds donc il est allé demander des
fonds un investisseur qui lui a dit non
parce que bon ben pourquoi est-ce que je
lui prêterait à lui plutôt qu'un autre
il avait quelque chose de très simple il
a filmé l'écran de son ordinateur
il a commencé à synchroniser des
fichiers à mettre des fichiers dans un
dossier
il les a copié sur un autre ordinateur
il a filmé cet écran là il a fait une
modification sur cet ordinateur
il a recopié le fichier chalex sur
l'écran d'ordinateur précédent et en
montant la vidéo des deux écrans il a
fait genre il y avait un système de
synchronisation mais en fait je n'avais
pas il a mis sur internet en 48 heures
il a eu je crois quelque chose comme
90000 préinscription est bien quand vous
avez ce genre de chiffres
vous pouvez vous dire bon ça vaut le
coup de le faire et c'est comme ça que
dropbox a commencé ce genre d'histoire
vous pouvez la voir pour un nombre
incroyable de produits et parfois vous
vous en doutez même pas si vous vouliez
faire un über vous pouvez commencer avec
deux téléphones vous appelez le chauffe
enfin vous le client vous appelle vous
appelez le chauffeur vous les fait se
parler et puis ils s'arrangent entre eux
avant de développer une application
on pourrait prendre à peu près n'importe
quel produit et le rendre extrêmement
simple même si vous regardez la première
version de facebook était d'une
simplicité incroyable
tapez facebook via chanoine sur internet
vous aurez sûrement un résultat assez
surprenant tout est faisable de manière
simple pour pouvoir tester
c'est ce qu'on appelle le produit
minimum viable c'est à dire l'expression
la plus simple de la solution vous
voulez proposer pour votre marché et
pourquoi est ce qui est très important
de la trouver parce que cette solution
extrêmement simple elle va vous
permettre de tester votre solution
elle va vous permettre de tester votre
hypothèse est ce que l'hypothèse que
vous faites sur votre marché
face à votre problème est la bonne à
partir du moment où vous savez que c'est
la bonne vous avez déjà franchi une
étape
et puis ensuite elle reste du
développement de la start up reste
développement de l'entreprise ce qui est
important de comprendre dans une start
up c'est qu'elle se définit par une
croissance qui est exponentielle et le
principe de base de ça c'est que chaque
utilisateur que vous rajouter dans
l'entreprise génère plus de revenus que
le précédent ça veut dire que vos
rendements sont croissants en économie
d'arriver à ces rendements croissants
c'est ce qui vous permet d'aller vite
mais ça veut dire qu'une start-up se
structure vit un peu différemment d'une
entreprise conventionnel pourquoi parce
qu'elle doit gérer cette croissance
ça veut dire que tout va très vite et
c'est pour ça que si vous voulez vous
lancer
si vous voulez vous lancer dans une
aventure entrepreneuriale de type start
up vous avez intérêt à vous lancer vite
car c'est un monde qui va vite et vous
verrez que il faudra en permanence
accéléré et c'est là qu'on en revient
aux vertus fondamentales de
l'entrepreneur ski formidable chez
entrepreneur c'est leur capacité à
apprendre très rapidement leurs
capacités à apprendre toujours plus de
choses et si on prend des entrepreneurs
que j'ai vu commencé il ya 4 5 ans
maintenant sont les pros au moment ils
ont commencé et si on les prend
maintenant on a l'impression plus voir
les mêmes personnes
et donc si vous voulez vous lancer dans
cette aventure là ce qui est important
de retenir ce qu'il faut aller vite pour
le faire ne sous-estimez jamais les
outils que vous avez à votre disposition
c'est facile aujourd'hui de créer une
entreprise
c'est devenu simple alors si vous voulez
le faire vous devriez le faire
maintenant parce que c'est un monde qui
va vite et plutôt vous le ferez plus
grand sera votre votre gain par ailleurs
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens dans
cette salle qui sont étudiants et vous
avez un avantage énorme en étant
étudiant c'est que pour l'instant
vous n'avez rien à perdre a priori vous
n'avez pas encore de famille de capital
de patrimoine & vous pouvez vous
permettre de prendre un risque à ce
moment là ça veut pas dire que vous
pouvez pas le faire plus tard mais vous
avez un avantage exceptionnel à le faire
alors je vous en prie faites le merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]